hey guys Ryan right here I kind of got a
busy night ahead of me I'm gonna go meet
Sally's mom tonight you know meet the
future in-law as they say Oh
Murray's right there so she just got
back from work so she's all greasy
wet like her what's up baby marina I
don't have that kind of friendship where
I can hit on her there's been about like
50 people I actually counted so far 50
people I got all these notifications all
day from many different videos and they
all said the same thing you gotta watch
the new Asia Godzilla trailer the Asia
Godzilla trailer there's a trailer for
all of Asia apparently according to
people here I could be wrong I'm going
off of what you guys are saying if you
guys are wrong or if you're bullshitting
me you know you're lying how cool would
it be if I hooked up with Sally's mom
that would be a story and I totally
share it on this channel whatever it is
that's in there what the [ __ ] is there
guarding so carefully it's real whoa
can you kill it oh damn I believe
something can
Godzilla
monster no oh god oh oh what a cool plot
[Music]
[Music]
sadie is your boy
the organs of man is thinking nature is
in our control and not the other way
around so exciting okay so it's like the
[ __ ] LA traffic dude this movies
right around the corner can you believe
that [ __ ] it feels like it's still far
away but man this is like the one of the
best promotions I've ever seen of a
movie I guess it's like monsters are
attacking and then they wake in the God
of all zillah's to go fight for them and
they're just kind of in the war I don't
know either way that's sweet because I
was concerned that the other monsters
would be distracting and in the Godzilla
movie cuz I thought like oh god Zoe's a
terror then there's all these other
monsters all of a sudden but no they're
having it makes sense perfectly and I'm
excited for this man it just looks
[ __ ] epic this might be my favorite
movie of the year
next to x-men Days of Future past in
City - the amazing spider-man - can't
think of anything else that's good thank
you guys for recommending that trailer
all 5,000 of you that was really [ __ ]
sweet outside okay if anyone's gonna ask
this question you know it's gonna be me
do you think we'll get to see Godzilla's
huge dick
comment below anyway if you guys are new
to the channel subscribe that would be
my performance as one of the extras in
Godzilla oh yeah I'd be that extra who
really wants to stand out and thinks
this is his big shot extras bunch of
nobodies [ __ ] actors no if you're next
you're gonna freak anyway it's that time
with the video guys before I head out to
go fix my phone and bang Sally's mom
shoutout time okay I've been wanting to
show these guys out for a while now and
they're gonna be a pair here this is
gonna count as one shout out justin
Malvin room all Ventana shirt and
fernando Vasquez these guys are [ __ ]
cool man
they created an app like these guys
legitimately created an app that like
you can download
I've called slinger don't know how to
explain it efficiently so I'm gonna give
an example of how slinger works I
totally downloaded it
I realize how [ __ ] sweet it is let's
say it's Murray's birthday I'm not there
to be there for her on her birthday at
some awesome bar so what I can do
I could use my slinger app and then
order a drink for her at the bar have
the bartender deliver it to her and give
her a personalized message that I say it
could be like you get me hard but I
would never tell you that Murray so you
know like it would be great if you're
like in a long-distance relationship or
if you're like cheating on your troll so
download that app called slinger if
you're a guy you got to get it you just
got to get it if you're a girl you just
got to get it you got to get if you're a
[ __ ] you just got to get it you got
to get it my point is go get it August
in mx2 604 yep gonna write this dude
just turn 18
that means strip club I'm gonna tell you
guys a little secret I have never been
to a strip club I was in a relationship
when I was 18 and then that lasted for a
good few years I never had the chance to
go to a strip club so if any male
subscribers or female that would be even
ten times cooler live in California and
are a good radiused mild thing away from
me we should go to the strip club and
yes August and MF to 604 I'm inviting
you I'm gonna make sure you two lap
pants I'm gonna even buy you a hooker a
black hooker I hear they're the best out
of all the hookers it's the black girls
that rock the most
so did Thai chicks I know that from
personal experience anyway dude yeah
happy [ __ ] birthday hope you have a
great year of being 18 live it up do
them not just [ __ ] make a bunch of
memories that you wish you didn't do
live life with guilt and regret all in
love with a chick who's gonna break your
[ __ ] hearts do whatever you got to do
man telling you 18 is gonna be awesome
Kevin harp this guy he makes one too
many threats that I didn't even I
stopped writing them down because they
were just one too many threats I'm
pretty sure and somehow involves my
genitalia genitalia word sweet the
vocabulary on this guy and I never went
to college this dude has really been
wanting a shout-out so here's your
shoutout
enjoy the shoutout harp if he
threatening me one more time I'm gonna
kick your [ __ ] ass but other than
that thanks for being to subscribe
around the channel Kevin